[Music]
your problem is never knowing when to
shut up but i'm gonna help you with that
ready you see this look on my face this
will always mean it's time to shut up
but
i
in 2021 streaming giant netflix drops
some of the year's most binge-worthy
series and while some streaming services
still rely on the old appointment
viewing model and release episodes week
to week we love netflix's full season
drop so we can binge to our hearts
content
this is the front mess speaking
preparations for the first game are
complete
you can begin now honestly there is so
much content out there it's hard to keep
up but netflix was full of surprises
this year from the resounding success of
squid game to the masterfully crafted
midnight mass so join us as we look back
on the streamers most popular shows this
year as determined by rotten tomatoes
visitors and count down the best netflix
shows of 2021
[Music]
number 10 sex education season three
socially awkward high school student
otis may not have much experience in the
love making department but he gets good
guidance on the topic in his personal
sex ed course living with mom gene who
is a sex therapist being surrounded by
manuals videos and tediously open
conversations about sex otis has become
a reluctant expert on the subject when
his classmates learn about his home life
otis decides to use his insider
knowledge to improve his status at
school so he teams up with whipsmart bad
girl maeve to set up an underground sex
therapy clinic to deal with their
classmates problems but through his
analysis of teenage sexuality otis
realizes that he may need some therapy
of his own starring asa butterfield
jillian anderson emma mackey and created
by lori nunn critics say with a
seemingly endless desire to dive deeper
into its characters paired perfectly
with its talented ensemble sex education
third season is a master class in
brutally honest brilliantly heartfelt
comedy that's nice
it's not but thank you
dad i'm
i'm stuck
dad
what are you doing i'm dropping biscuit
my balance
my help you know it is
oh
oh
oh sorry paint
where's mom
i can't waste a hobnob
oh your mom got called in for a cover
shift at the hospital well why didn't
you call me i could have come back i
didn't want to ruin your date
speaking of
do i finally get to meet the famous otis
it is my dad roland dad otis
oh hi there's nice to meet you
okay you've met now so thanks for
helping off you go go but you just got
here oh just stay for a bit let's let's
hang no dad
please don't say hang on don't worry
i'll put on my dressing can how about
that that sounds great
that'll be my weed dealer
number nine lupon a retelling of the
classic french story about arsene lupon
the world famous gentleman thief and
master of disguise starring omar sai
ludivine sonier clautild m and created
by george k and francois uzon critics
say omar sai effortlessly hits every
mark in lupon an engrossing espionage
thriller that lives up to its source
material and then some say
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
number eight the sinner season four
detective harry ambrose investigates a
chilling new homicide each season he
employs some unusual tactics and a deep
capacity for empathy to solve his cases
his boundless dedication is driven by
his dark past leading him into powerful
and often dangerously intimate bonds
with his suspects the sinner is a blend
of a thrilling murder investigation and
raw character drama creating an
electrifying ride with standout
performances the series was originally
adapted from the novel of the same name
by petra hamsfar however the book's
darker outlook was toned down and the
location was shifted from germany to
upstate new york starring bill pullman
jessica hecht francis fisher and
developed by derek simons matt roche of
tv insider says the sinner is played
with brooding subtlety and an
inscrutable squint by pullman harry's
psyche is often as disturbing as the
mysteries he solves in this unsettling
series so you're fully retired now
yeah it's over a year
i guess it was time
it sounds like you deserve it
i mean the stuff that said when you told
me i
i still can't believe what you both went
through with that
psychopath
was his name again
jamie burns
oh i'm sorry i didn't meet you that's
okay that's okay it's it's just been a
bit of a process
yeah
that's why we needed a change of scenery
so so tell me what's um
what's this about you giving up on the
male noobs that cannot be for real i
guess yeah i uh
after everything with jamie it just
didn't feel right anymore i want to
paint
light now
the sky
you know i i think i'm going to leave
you two to catch up and i'm gonna take a
stroll
oh okay
number seven cowboy bebop
a ragtag crew of bounty hunters chases
down the galaxy's most dangerous
criminals and they'll save the world for
the right price starring john cho
mustafa shakir daniela pineda and
developed by christopher yost critics
say maybe next time space cowboy this
live action bebop has a fun enough crew
to spend time with but it
disappointingly replaces the soulfulness
of the source material with kitsch can i
help you
yeah you can kindly off it's nothing
personal but your mark's coming with me
look i don't know what you're trying to
pull but i was here first he's mine the
boyfriend don't get about him i'm after
her what
one if you don't get that gun off of me
i'm gonna make you eat it and two why
the hell would anyone care about her
there's no bounty on her oh i care about
her because ellis montgomery does so
pack up your bags princess cause daddy
wants you home no
wait no no no no no no
she's katarina montgomery she's got to
read a montgomery please help me i can't
go back there i know but a whole lot of
money says otherwise you don't know him
you don't know what he's like everyone
knows your dad rich powerful total dick
get over it and move walk away
now
i don't know if you've noticed boy toy
[Applause]
number six money heist part five
a criminal mastermind who goes by the
professor has a plan to pull off the
biggest heist in recorded history to
print billions of euros in the royal
mint of spain to help him carry out the
ambitious plan he recruits eight people
with certain abilities and who have
nothing to lose the group of these take
hostages to aid in their negotiations
with the authorities who strategize to
come up with a way to capture the
professor and as more time elapses the
robbers prepare for a showdown with the
police starring pedro alonso ursula
corvero alvaro morte and created by alex
pina natalie marcos of el pais spain
says money heist had everything to lose
it has won again and buy a landslide
is
number five you season three
what would you do for love for a
brilliant male bookstore manager who
crosses paths with an aspiring female
writer this question is put to the test
a charming yet awkward crush becomes
something even more sinister when the
writer becomes the manager's obsession
using social media and the internet he
uses every tool at his disposal to
become close to her even going so far as
to remove any obstacle including people
that stands in his way of getting to her
starring penn badgley victoria pedretti
saffron burrows and created by greg
berlanti and sarah gamble critics say u
takes its thrilling saga to the suburbs
with superb results made all the more
delicious by penn badgley and victoria
pedretti's committed performances
hey
sherry
i don't know
what you think you heard
there you go
that's gonna end badly for love too
sherry was krav maga ah
go to sleep buddy
[Applause]
[Music]
number four midnight mass the arrival of
a charismatic priest brings miracles
mysteries and renewed religious fervor
to a dying town starring zach gilford
kate siegel homish linklater and created
by mike flanagan critics say an
ambitious meditation on grief and faith
that is as gorgeous as it is unsettling
midnight mass's slow boil is a triumph
of terror that will leave viewers
shaking and thinking long after the
credits roll after the towers
muslim officers were promoted fast
especially if we knew the language like
linguistic knowledge cultural knowledge
i mean we were very desirable for that
but it started to occur to them
with so many of us on the force elevated
to positions of real authority
what if that had been our plan
all along
what if we were interlopers
what if we were infiltrators
what if we
were double agents
and they [ __ ] panicked
internal affairs was suddenly all over
us we're being followed we're being
recorded civilians too surveilled at
mosques cafes and suddenly i'm out of
plain clothes
and i'm back in uniform
night shift streepy
and more and more
i realize i've lost their trust
number three the witcher season two the
witcher geralt a mutated monster hunter
struggles to find his place in a world
in which people often prove more wicked
than beasts starring henry cavill anya
chalotra freya allen and created by
lauren schmidt hyssrick critics say the
witcher's second season expands on its
first in all the best ways and most
importantly it remains a whole lot of
fun my
unfortunately yes
take siri
i'll find you afterwards
come on
there's no way out
what do we do
i don't know most powerful mage girl's
ever known right
it's complicated
number two arcane league of legends
the origins of two iconic league
champions set in the utopian piltover
and the oppressed underground of zan
starring hayley steinfeld katie long
kevin alejandro and created by alex yee
and christian link critics say arcane
makes an arresting first impression
combining a spectacular mix of 2d and 3d
animation with an emotionally compelling
story to deliver a video game adaptation
that could become legendary
uh
oh
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
masters of the universe revelation
the war for eternia begins again in what
may be the final battle between he-man
and skeletor starring chris wood mark
hamill lena hedy and created by kevin
smith critics say armed with an
incredible voice cast revelation smartly
updates masters of the universe while
retaining the quirky charms of the
original to create a show that's bound
to please fans and newcomers alike
[Music]
i look forward to our next hustle but i
won't hold my breath
[Music]
[Music]
what if we painted the ship a nice
granite
thanks to man at arms you're all wet
skeletor
sweet tooth
on a perilous adventure in a
post-apocalyptic world a boy who's half
human and half deer searches for a new
beginning with a gruff protector
starring christian converie non-so a
nosey a deal actar and developed by jim
michael critics say emotionally engaging
superbly acted and incredibly
entertaining sweet tooth will satisfy
fantasy fans of all ages what do you
look bigger than the others
yeah
older tim
you think of what i'm thinking
we take it to the lab
we bring them east
this one's too
i got you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
hey
it's yours
maid
single mother alex turns to house
cleaning to make ends meet as she
escapes an abusive relationship and
overcomes homelessness to create a
better life for her daughter maddie
starring margaret quali nick robinson
anika nonai rose and created by molly
smith metzler critics say may takes
great care with its sensitive subject
matter to craft a drama that is not
always easy to watch but undeniably
powerful grounded by an outstanding
performance by margaret quali so you on
parole
um no
got any priors
no don't lie i'm gonna check you got a
problem with background check
no
we paid that
no exceptions bump you up 50 cents once
the background check clears and you go
full-time
full-time great yes but full-time in a
40-hour week company policy is you can't
work more than six hours a day breaks my
heart it really does but i can't be
paying benefits
so it's capped
six hours a day max
okay
and tour season's over so i really only
have one shift open it's a weekly
three-hour clean over on fisher island
one shift okay
so uniforms 25 bucks
comes out of your first check
and finally number one squid game
hundreds of cash-strapped contestants
accept an invitation to compete in
children's games for a tempting prize
but the stakes are deadly starring lee
jung-jae pakisu oh youngsu and created
by huangdong hyuk critics say squid
game's unflinching brutality is not for
the faint of heart but sharp social
commentary and a surprisingly tender
core will keep viewers glued to the
screen even if it's while watching
between their fingers
[Applause]
said
yes
god
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the ron
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you